you
my days are kind of controlled by my
projects so sometimes their album covers
sometimes they're commissioned portraits
shoots sometimes they are editorial so
it kind of I don't dictate it
I guess I'm half traditionalist half
modern girl and I just never I love the
digital world and i love electronica and
after I shoot everything is digital but
I just I don't know I love my camera's I
love contact sheets i love the the
visceral thing of film and i'm not
positive that I can replicate my
lighting digitally my assistants tell me
I can but just stubborn I guess
that's the least interesting part of my
work I kind of you learn it you master
it and then you make sure that it just
disappears you know like if I could have
invisible lights I would an invisible
cameras I'm just really trying to get at
my subject and I respect the technical
aspect but it's not anything that I
think about at this point
for me there's several components to
picture taking and it starts with it my
goals as an artist it's capturing I
guess the inner life of my subject and
then it is giving them their idealized
version of themselves we all look in the
mirror and see us a little blonder or a
little thinner or a little younger
whatever that ideal might be and most of
the people that I'm photographing are
selling something you know whether
they're on the front of an album cover
our magazine or they're a corporate
person ready to switch companies or a
doctor selling skincare line so I want
to help them achieve that and when i
worked at motown records the head of the
label called it you know he'd say diva
you need to fix them so he called it
fixing people and that's that's really
the joy of what I do is really not to
fix them but to give them the them that
they want to be visually and a big part
of that is for me is obviously making
them comfortable making sure that our
because it's a dance you know a photo
session is really a dance and making
sure that they're comfortable and for me
it's the music the music the music
that's everything so I do select a
soundtrack for each of my subjects and
again my assistants you know they make
fun of me because that's more important
to me than the lighting which I just do
it in a minute right before but I spend
a long time on the soundtracks
a lot of the people that I photograph
our master musicians themselves whether
they're singers are or great jazz
players and it's kind of fun to figure
out who they came up with and who they
emulated or who they idolized actually
and that's just it's a wonderful way to
get at who someone is through their own
love of music and going right at their
subconsciousness if you will I you don't
play girl singers for girls singers you
know there's certain things you do play
Ellington for Bobby McFerrin sometimes
like for teddy pendergrass teddy has the
whole lineage that came before his solo
career with Harold Melvin and the blue
notes so he has a signature song the
love I lost so I planned it I got him
ready there he was we put on the love I
lost and the minute he heard that bass
solo boom there there was the album
cover for joy and it really was joy
that's the title because it was it was
that visceral memory for him so
sometimes it's an outright manipulation
like that but most of the time I'm I'm
just I'm creating a mood that is a place
of comfort for the person and a wafer
for our dialogue to be more fluid